Film Courage: You’re saying the interrogation
process works when there’s another person
interrogating them?
Mark W. Travis: Yes.
Film Courage: Let’s take something where…slightly
different scenario…maybe I am making a different
way around it in that…let’s take a movie
like THE REVENANT and let’s take Hugh Glass’s
character before the bear attack.
He’s alone in the forest.
How are you interrogating Hugh Glass to stumble
across the bear or encountering it in some
way?
How are you getting him ready for this scene?
Mark W. Travis: Okay…first I am just getting
back to what you said in the beginning about
interrogating involves someone else.
The interrogation process is usually between
someone who is not in the scene and the person
who is in the scene.
So whether there is one person in the scene
or 12 people makes no difference.
Each actor needs that other person and it’s
usually someone who is not in the scene.
But getting to how do you interrogate someone
to play a scene like Hugh Glass’s scene
where he is going through the forest (the
woods) and then he’s attacked by a bear.
One thing you’ve got to be very clear about,
the interrogation is pretty simple yet profound
for a moment like that.
But first of all you’ve got to remember
in any scene, the character that you are interrogating
does not know what’s coming up in the scene.
This is a problem between the character and
actor.
The actor knows.
Leonardo DiCaprio, he knows exactly what’s
going to happen.
There is going to be a bear and he’s going
to have to fight it off.
Got it!
The character doesn’t know that.
This is the power of interrogation.
I’ve got to get his mind back into the character’s
mind and away from the actor’s mind.
What the actor knows (this is a little detour),
what the actor knows what’s coming up in
the scene, the lines I have to say, what I
have to do, that’s all there in the background,
okay.
It’s not driving anything because it can’t
drive it, because it’s not known by the
character.
I will trust that it will always be there.
I will trust that the actors will always say
their lines.
They’ll follow the stage and they’ll do
the mechanics.
So it’s not the mechanics I am worried about,
I’m worried about the mindset of the characters.
So interrogating Hugh Glass before the bear,
I have to know and so does Hugh Glass have
to know, what the hell are you doing?
What are you doing?
Where are you going into and what are you
expecting?
Now in the interrogation I could say okay
I could be talking to him where are you going.
Okay you’ve got to go.
You’re going to get that?
Let’s say he’s looking for food!
I’m just making this up because I don’t
recall what he was doing, he’s just moving
but Hugh Glass knows what he’s doing!
Even if we look at the scene we’re not sure…he
knows what he’s doing and through the interrogation
I am going to plant in his mind or inject
or question and we’re going to establish
through me and Hugh Glass what he’s doing,
what he’s looking for, right?
Now through that interrogation I could start
to insinuate potential danger, you know?
“You’re all alone.
You’re all alone out here.
I mean, what if something happens?”
Now he knows as the actor I’m setting the
character for what the environment and what’s
going on and actually setting the character
up for the scene.
The actor knows that because there is a bear
coming.
Hugh Glass is just saying “Yeah, I know
I’m staying but I’m fine.
I’ve got my rifle.
I’m fine.”
I said “You sure?
Could you handle something…what if an Elk
comes?”
I want to get him into our mindset, a specific
mindset of my choice.
The mindset could be “I’m fine.
I’m in no danger at all.”
That’s one mindset!
Another mindset is “I know I’m out here
alone and I shouldn’t be and this is the
stupidest thing you should ever do.”
That’s a different mindset!
Where do I want to take him?
What mindset do I want to put him in?
I can set up that mindset and then the beauty
of interrogation is you work with the character,
you’re interrogating the character and you
set up a mindset, a belief system and attitude
just before the scene.
A lot of actors will talk about that moment
before the scene where what they are thinking
about just before the scene, the interrogation.
I can create that, anything I want and then
what I do (which I love) is then I send them
into the scene naive.
An actor will go into the scene with a plan.
This is disastrous because when’s the last
time you went into a 3-minute moment in your
life with a plan knowing what you were going
to say and what you were going to do and how
you were going to react.
We don’t do that!
That’s not authentic, “It’s acting.”
My job is to send my character into a scene
naive having no idea what’s going to come
on because I want the genuine authentic reactions
to be events that happen to the other lines
that are said, to the attack of the bear,
to the realization that he’s been stupid…whatever.
I want it to happen authentically.
I don’t want him to plan it.
The actor will try to plan it.
The character can’t plant it.
So if I get him in the mind of the character
believing something totally different than
what’s going to happen then he will react
to every single moment authentically and it
will probably surprise him and it will probably
surprise me.
The guarantees I can make to every director.
If you work this way and you send a character
into a scene, naive without a plan, knowing
that yes the actor will say the right lines
and do the blocking and do all of that.
But without a plan for the emotional journey
he’s going to go through.
How he’s going to react to anything with
no plan I’m guaranteed number one: the actor
will not know what he’s going to do…at
all.
Certainly the character doesn’t know because
the character is just going through it.
Actor one: you will not know what he’s going
to do but everything he does will be authentic
and that’s what we’re going for and then
you get to choose in post-production as we’ve
talked about before which moment and then
when you do take two you set him up slightly
differently, a different mindset.
Maybe a more cautious mindset this time for
Hugh Glass.
Maybe a mindset of deriding himself “You
stupid, okay what are you doing out here?”
Trying to convince himself he’s going to
be okay and he shouldn’t be out there.
He will react differently then.
If you do it three or four takes like that
and he reacts differently and you’ve shot
them all, you realize the range of material
you’ve got and it’s all authentic.
You can build the most beautiful scene possible.